[Musik]
was heißt hallo auf spanisch ich kann
noch nicht aus dieser sprache übersetzen
königin in der küche wenn du möchtest
kann ich im internet suchen wir ihnen
die königin der küche im internet zu was
auf spanisch oder und herzlich
willkommen so salis battles heute wird
spanisch wir werden empanadas machen
oder besser gesagt im paradies ja also
ich sag mal so viel dazu ich glaube
dieses teig gericht gibt es in vielen
nationalitäten im russischen dem
türkischen im deutschen im ungarischen
damit hat die spanische variante gewählt
die sie die spanische variante und zwar
ist es ein richtig toller knuspriger
teig der ganz einfach herzustellen ist
innen drin habe ich eine hackfleisch
füllung ein teil habe ich mit rosinen
gemacht nämlich mit rosen und korinthen
gemacht ein ohne auf vollgas ich mag die
mit korinthen am meisten
und dann werden sie in der friteuse
gebacken und schaut so ein fingerfood
und man kann es kalt und warm essen gibt
es ja ich liebe das glück nicht
aber wie gesagt ist genauso ein paar
spanien es anders essen
ja auf jeden fall vor allem die füllung
wird hat auch mal anders gemacht und ich
habe hier zwei verschiedene muster und
zwar immer mit der gabel gedrückt sieht
schön aus und einmal dieses muster hier
was ich viel typischer finde wenn die
spanische küche
so haben es auch beim spannen gegessen
was super lecker und ich zeige euch hier
zuerst einmal wie man den teig herstellt
und dafür die zutaten für den teig
brauche ich 750 gramm mehl 150 gramm
butter oder butterschmalz zwei teelöffel
salz 1 eigelb und 250 milliliter kaltes
wasser
den teig könnte jetzt entweder mit den
händen verkneten oder mit der
küchenmaschine ich mache das jetzt hier
oben im mixer so geht es für mich am
einfachsten
da kommt jetzt das mehl ein ich mache
jetzt erstmal noch nicht alles und geben
hier das butterschmalz mit dazu
und auch das salz und kann die zutaten
jetzt erstmal verbinden
hier kommt jetzt das eigelb noch mit
rein wasser und das restliche mehl und
da kann ich den teig einfach kurz
verkneten
das war jetzt ziemlich viel teig den
rest vom mehl knete ich jetzt einfach
kurz mit der hand unter und kann dann
den teig verpacken und etwa eine halbe
stunde ruhen lassen und die zeit nutze
ich dann um die füllung vorzubereiten
[Musik]
für die füllung nämlich 50 gramm butter
schmalz 500 gramm hackfleisch vom rind
für zwiebeln da habe ich jetzt zwei
weise und zwei rote eine knoblauchzehe
einen esslöffel mehl hätte gewürze salz
paprikapulver chili pfeffer und majoran
100 milliliter gemüsebrühe drei
hartgekochte eier und wer möchte nimmt
noch ein paar corinna zuerst gebe ich
das butterschmalz sitzt in einen großen
topf oder eine große pfanne und dabei
durch erhitzen und das hackfleisch von
anbraten und die zwischenzeit kann ich
nutzen um die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen
fein zu schneiden
jetzt ist das hackfleisch krümelig
angebraten und jetzt kommen die zwiebel
und knoblauch würfel dazu und werden
dann für etwa 45 minuten mit gebratenen
bis sie auch richtig schön weit sind
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt das mehl dazu und wird
kurz eingerührt und jetzt kann ich das
hackfleisch ablöschen mit der
gemüsebrühe und die gewürze einrühren
da könnt ihr auch gerne gehört zu eurer
wahl nehmen oder das ganze noch ein
bisschen schärfer machen aber ich muss
jetzt lieber weglassen weil die kids mit
essen und dann mache ich das generell
immer zu scharf also wird sich lieber
danach nochmal mit chili nur bei meinen
eigenen sagen wenn sich dann alles gut
verbunden hat kann der herz schon
ausgemacht werden
und jetzt kommen hier noch die
gewürfelten hartgekochte eier mit dazu
die machen die füllung auch so richtig
cremig und die corinth und die mache ich
dann nur in die hälfte der füllung und
ich mag sie ganz gerne murat maxi nicht
also machen wir zwei verschiedene jetzt
dürfte der teig hohen die füllung ist
auch abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich den
teig ausrollen dafür halte ich ihn jetzt
erstmal
und jetzt auf etwas mehl ausrollen
so etwa einen millimeter dünn
hier oben hab ich kein mehl drauf beim
zusammenkleben hält es so einfach ein
bisschen besser und jetzt könnt ihr euch
den aussteller nehmen oder zum beispiel
ein großes gefäß und das hat jetzt zehn
zentimeter im durchmesser
je größer umso größer werden natürlich
auch die empanadas
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die schulung an die reihe
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach ein eis
portionierer hoch damit ich besser
klettern kann und gibt es hier nicht
ganz mittig sondern er versetzt auf den
teig
und jetzt glaube ich sitze also zu einem
halbmond und daher ist es besser wir uns
eben versetzt drauflegt und jetzt gut
mit den fingern an drücken damit schön
verschlossen bleibt
und wer möchte kann auch eine gabel
leben und mit der gabel den rand ein
bisschen eindrücken
[Musik]
hier ist die eine variante mit der gabel
jetzt kommt die zweite variante und es
ist auch immer ganz gut wenn man zwei
verschiedene füllungen hat dass man auch
zwei verschiedenen frauen hat
denn nach dem auspacken erkennt man
sofort welche füllung wo drin ist hier
habe ich jetzt wieder detail klappen
oder teig reise zugeklappt und jetzt
kommt der fehler ins spiel und zwar wird
hier außen jetzt der teig eingeklappt
also die ecke dann im kleinen finger an
drücken dann wieder von außen nehmen und
rein drücken und so kommt ein richtig
tolles und schönes muster zustande
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kann ich dir im phanar astrid
ihren ich mach das jetzt in der friteuse
das fed habe ich bereits auf 170 grad
erhitzt ihr könnt aber natürlich auch in
einem topf machen
jetzt lege ich dir hier rein und dann
werden sie goldbraun frittiert
[Musik]
gedacht wird probieren morax bisschen
abkühlen lassen
nimmst du die ohne korinthen ironie
kunden also konnten sich je sehen sein
sein fall probiert mal also auch ganz
cool in die hand zu nehmen und google
super sie könnten allerdings noch etwas
schärfer sein
dafür gibt es das mit tabasco kam ich
dann dazu machen ich hab jetzt nicht mit
rein weil er die kids mit essen kann ich
mir verpasst man lebt die extra
scorpions extra scorpion ja und zwar
nochmal das ist die marke nicht zeigen
oder das mag nicht zeigen zeigt man die
marken nicht aber das ist ein ganz ganz
spezielle so sie gibt es wirklich ganz
ganz selten zwischen liga titel vision
wie heißt die scorpions scorpions ist
nicht gut sondern jubiläumsedition ich
habe mich gesagt dass die extra scharf
ist und dann brennt wird der name macht
sandra schmidt es ging ja ganz oft
liefern aber gut auf jeden fall bei lage
richtig gejagt beilage als fingerfood
für die wm zum beispiel egal wie
probiert auf jeden fall mal aus markante
theoretisch auch einfrieren
dafür würde ich sie vorher ist denn an
frittieren und dann einzeln aber so
viele sind es schon
auch wir nicht und von daher kennt auch
den weg zu bereiten und die wird auf
jeden fall kehrt also bis zum nächsten
mal
foto schon gemacht oder lesen alles
schon gemacht heißt es jetzt nicht so
scharf besteigen hinweise in chili
nehmen spiele scorpion wahnsinn
[Musik]